[Music]
hello everyone its Pete also known as
snail dough here for the iron Lords
podcast I will read a review for this
game called eSports life tycoon by the
developer you play online now we were
given this key to do a little bit of an
impression video for you guys for a
first look of how this game is and I
asked to give it a try
the reason for that is I actually have
played a very similar game called
youtuber life which is very very similar
now there are lots of different there's
lots of similarities between the two
games but one of the most interesting
things is this one is surrounded by
eSports now the East for genre as many
people know is not only one type of game
eSports as first-person shooters
MOBAs world first type raids things like
that it's not just one type of game now
for instance this game I was able to
play it for probably about three hours
before I started getting a little a
little tired of it because it had one
type of game from what I saw and that
was League of Legends type gameplay one
of the things I wanted to add was the
customizing the customizing portion of
this I thought was really really cool
because all five of your first team
members you were able to customize what
they were look like what their clothes
were and you could essentially make your
team almost exactly 100% how you wanted
them to look or your eSports shirts what
like how they looked and where your team
was from and I thought that was really
cool and your you were you were the
owner so you were able to customize your
character also so he ended up looking
the way you wanted him to look now as
for the game itself
the graphics of it are pretty on point
it's just like youtubers life was which
I played it's got to be almost two years
ago maybe three years ago and the the
animations of the people are very clean
crisp and I really liked that aspect of
it as for the gameplay it was very fluid
very clicky it was one of those games
that you could use as a time sink so
it's just you know here and there it's
like okay and we're gonna click here
we're gonna click there okay cool
this is cool okay cool now one of the
things that I found most interesting was
the concept of the game the concept of
the game was to produce an eSports team
to allow you to make money through
sponsors and to make sure that your team
was able to compete in these
competitions and you were making money
for your sponsor for yourself and for
your team and you did that in a couple
of different ways the well it's actually
really one way of doing it
but the way you did it was you built
your team you got your five people right
from the start which is fantastic but if
somebody got hurt you had to recruit
another player to come in to fill up
your team and you could pick what slot
if it's a first start or a back string
person or captain it was very very much
more intricate almost like a type of
sports game like a baseball game or a
football game where you have to trade
your characters and and you're priming
your players and you know all those all
that of that type of gameplay and if
you're used for its members actually had
arguments you have to actually go in
there and say hey you got to stop
arguing you know and you talk to them or
you can have them go punch a punching
bag or something like that so that they
weren't angry anymore
now for the options that you had from
the ones that I saw were you had a and
analyze which was you pretty much
scoping out the other team to see what
they were doing I think that's the that
was called a scouting if you will and
then another one was gameplay so you can
actually go and you play your game and
you can you know make her team more
cohesive or you had your I think it was
um your strategy type part of it now
that chemistry that's what it was
chemistry
now the chemistry side of it also you
know it was with your team to see who
better doing what doing this and that
and then your final thing was your
height bar so your height bar you ended
up taking that and you ended up seeing
how how many followers you can get and
more followers you got when you won a
competition you got more money so if you
had one bars 25% two bars fifty so on
and so forth or four bars which is a
hundred percent which is a full amount
what you would get and I only was able
to get it two hundred percent once now
my characters were kind of low so it
wasn't really a fantastic job for me to
be able to do that but I was able to do
it now I am NOT a fan of League of
Legends so I went into this knowing
almost no information about what to do
and the game itself gave you a very
decent tutorial to go through the
process so that you would learn how to
play League of Legends now you'll see
some of that gameplay shortly now the
the meat and potatoes of the game was
this simulation MOBA if you will that
look very similar to League of Legends
now I'm not that in-depth with League of
Legends but you actually had to go
through the system of banning your hero
selecting which heroes your guys wanted
to play and then ended up going into
this map where you told your characters
which lanes to push and which ones you
thought were going to do better and I I
found myself just sitting there watching
the screen and I started getting really
really bored and I really I really had
high hopes and hoping that it had a lot
of different type of things you could do
and
just did not it was just the one it was
just the mobile from what I saw and I
was a little depressed about it but from
what I could see is like your characters
your your members your players if you
will they had certain players they could
pick that make them better at playing at
certain things and this had certain
things and I thought you know that
that's cool you know but I don't wanna
be sitting here doing a game like this
and having to make charts and
spreadsheets on which is gonna be a
better character for my character to
play I just want to be able to sit play
and joy and I was a little sad about
that but all the game was kind of cool
for the little bit of time I played it
and you know it was it was fun and you
know I'm not gonna sit there and say hey
you need to go out and go get it but you
know if it's on sale for like you know a
couple of bucks I'm talking like five
bucks I then you know pick it up you
know it's cool you know it's not that
it's not you know something you're gonna
sit and play for hours but so to thank
once again for the developer you play
online for for developing this game and
you know like I said before it's a very
cool game and a great concept but it
seems like it's lacking a lot of aspects
and it's very much pushing only one type
of genre of gameplay which I was very I
was very sad about so thank you very
much for for checking us out and just to
remember just to remind you the Ireland
podcast is on at twelve on Sundays so go
check us out on YouTube hit us up on
Twitter Instagram hit that sub button
thank you all for for checking out this
video and have a great day thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you